- All right.
I have one more story.
I hope will leave a smile on your face.
This is #WhatI'mLiking
(introduction jingle)
A Tennessee police officer
on a routine patrol
came across this sight;
an 84 year old grandmother
walking down a busy highway.
Turns out she was headed
to a hair appointment
but the bus only took her so far.
Who is this bus driver?
(audience laughs)
Just inquiring minds want to know.
Of course, the officer gave her a ride.
(audience laughter and applause)
- Even better than two
of since become friends.
So let's welcome them, say hello to Elle
and Officer Lance Hoffmeiser of the
Murphys Police Department.
Hello!
- Lance.
- How are y'all doing today?
First of all, Elle,
your hair looks amazing.
- Thank you.
(laughter)
- So do you normally walk
to your hair appointments?
- Well, no.
I take a car or a bus part-way.
It happened to be a
little different that day.
- You got, so you got some
exercises and steps in as well.
I, I love this though.
So Officer Lance, you're
now friends, right?
- Yeah, we, we have a
little funny banter together
and we're able to text every now
and again and I check on her every week.
She's since moved to North Carolina and
uh, my wife and I actually
plan on, on taking
a trip down to see her.
So we're super excited about that.
But I'm also sad that she moved away.
But I mean, like I said in the beginning,
um,
she reminded me of my
grandmother right away
and I, I just, you know
I always wanna check on her
make sure she's doing all right.
- Yeah. So Elle, is your new hair salon,
'cause you moved to North Carolina,
Is your new hair salon
a little bit closer?
- Well, it is a little harder to get
to because it's in the middle
of a whole lot of other little shops, but,
- Oh,
- Closer.
- Okay, okay, well first of all
I just want y'all to know I'm
liking your post right now.
That's the one thing.
But I ask about your salon, Elle,
because our season long
partner, Pilot Pin makers of G2
the go-to pin at the Kelly
Clarkson Show, want to
make sure you always have a
ride to your hair appointment.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars
that you can use for Ubers.
(audience cheers)
- There you go.
- That's amazing.
Thank you.
- Uber away.
And depending on where
you are in North Carolina
I have a lot of family there.
They might give you a ride.
Just lemme know where you are.
They're friendly.
You can trust them.
Well, thank you guys so much
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Jay Leno, Iowa, Devery di
and the Bad Moms of Comedy
or Lee, Leah and Co.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
well, try and change it.